You posted this great shot
of yourself as Joe Exotic.
This is what happens when A,
you have too much time on your hands,
and your wife was one of
the leading makeup artists
in the business.
We just went to the attic,
got the old makeup kit out,
and I spent an entire day
just having the most fun being Joe Exotic
and I put it up for fun,
and then the next thing you know,
Ryan Murphy was like, let's go out
and make this as a real movie.
So we went out and
tried to get the rights,
which of course were already gone.
Who has the rights?
Do you know who has the rights?
Turns out a consortium, 'cause I think,
is it always consortiums
that have rights as opposed to one person?
I think so, consortiums,
I always think of as evil, too,
which is probably true.
Well, Nick Cage is involved in it.
Oh, Nick Cage!
Oh my God, okay, yeah.
Nick Cage is always part
of every consortium.
Isn't he, though?
If there's a consortium
trying to buy up all the oil in Alaska,
Nick Cage is in there.
Yes, that's what I'm saying.
He's part of
every consortium.
Yeah, so it's a Nick Cage consortium.
[Conan] Oh my God.
But listen, I stand down
at the alter of Nick,
the notion of Nicholas
Cage as the Lion King.
I mean, I got nothing to offer there.
He'd be great, he'd be great.
But I got to say, the picture
had me wanting to see...
I thought this could happen when I saw it.
It is the role of a lifetime.
Like when I watched that,
I was like, you know,
'cause whenever I usually,
I don't get to do
hardcore character stuff.
I mean, when I did
"Behind the Candelabra,"
I got to do a lot and I love it
whenever I can do prosthetic stuff,
it's just a great escape for me,
and it's kind of freeing,
and I thought this would be great.
So I'm always looking
for something like it.
I forgot about "Behind the Candelabra."
That was fantastic.
And you had your character,
who's a plastic surgeon
had an insane amount of the
prosthetics they did on you.
You were completely absurd looking.
And then like most people
who've had terrible plastic surgery,
you were completely unaware
that you looked crazy.
That was my favorite
part of the character.
And not only that, I'm a bad surgeon.
So when I give Michael
Douglas his Liberace surgery,
he said, and it's got his
eyes pulled like this.
And he says, "Doctor, will my
eyes ever be able to close?"
And I say, "Probably not." (Conan laughs)
"But look at it this way,
"you'll always get to
see people's reactions
"when they see how great you look."
And I don't know if you noticed,
but I look very androgynous
and there was a lot of people
playing sort of faux androgynous stuff,
and I wanted to stand out.
So I was like, I'll look androgynous
but I'm going to use the voice of the guy
from the Men's Warehouse.
Yes, yeah.
"You're gonna like the way you look."
(Conan laughs)